hello Facebook I'm trying to cope well
here in the Toyota green room and I have
with me
I'm Jim Pereira from the New York Times
and you are editor of smarter living and
your latest newsletter is about it's
about mistakes mistakes mistakes
everybody makes them we all make them we
make them professionally we make them
personally all across the board and our
general reaction is well we tend to
think of these like huge monumental
mistakes as someone's gonna like change
the course of our life right but we just
need to kind of take a step back when we
make these huge huge mistakes and
realize everything's gonna be fine
everything's okay relax a little bit we
should clarify we don't just mean like
you know you ordered the double
cheeseburger and could've got was just a
single patty right we're talking about
choosing the wrong career yeah the wrong
or these huge life-changing things like
that yeah and so you know the first step
when we are in a position we're
wondering whether we've made the right
decision is to really just be very
honest and very truthful with ourselves
and think was this mistake and really be
open and kind of sincere about what we
actually did and whether it wasn't
mistake in the first place you know it's
really difficult to accept these huge
mistakes there's a lot of cognitive
biases that work against us there's
something called the commitment bias
well I believe what you're gonna bring
up is Vince Lombardi essentially write
quitters never win winners never quit
sure right stick to it America and in a
lot of times that's great but that you
know the committin bias is really plays
into that it's this idea that we let our
past behaviors and decisions influence
our current and future behaviors and oh
it's part of it that goes into it is we
generally want to be seen as people who
are consistent who maybe have
convictions who stick to it but you know
that can be good for that maybe you have
convictions sometimes but you know but
really it can negatively impact your
future decisions if you want to sort of
justify a past decision that you think
might be bad with future decisions that
play into that you're just compounding a
problem making it worse and so where
this is a Monday that we're having this
conversation yes your newsletter came
out on Monday if you got married on
Saturday and you woke up on Sunday you
thought this was a huge mistake
if anybody marriage advice but you know
the way out of these huge mistakes isn't
to make these rash decisions you know a
lot of times the reason that we get into
these situations is because we made a
rash decisions things that were
impulsive or that we weren't fully
informed about and so that's the last
thing we want to do so don't you know
run on your marriage on a Monday
forgotten on Saturday just wake up
before your partner's stare at them no
but you do want to kind of take a step
back and think what are kind of some
low-risk baby steps that you can take to
1 figure out the mistake to kind of be
okay with it and accept it um but when
you're going through this process you
want to be really careful not to let
that mistake define you or your
self-worth or your value because it's so
easy to fall into these cycles where you
start beating yourself up because you
thought you may be bad decision and then
it just turns into this kind of shame
spiral and you know there's studies that
show that once you kind of fall into
those it can have physical implications
for your health they can impact your
self-esteem it can impact your
decision-making ability and it can lead
to depression one of the things you
point out I think a lot of people are
probably dealing with right to second is
they made some mistake in in their mind
it is the most important and significant
thing that happened in the universe
yesterday yes and in fact it's not the
truth is we obsess about these because
we're seeing it firsthand because these
mistakes happen to us but the truth is
people have lives like you are not the
focal point of anybody else's life and
the mistake that you made yesterday is
not even on their radar it's actually
interesting how often I've brought
something up and been like you know I
really wanted to talk to you about
yesterday people like everybody we
realize that you know we are not the
center of the universe as much as we'd
like to think it's amazing how large I
lumen my own memory okay so we are we
are lesser then and mistakes happen they
happen they happen to everybody they're
going to continue to happen so like I
said you just want to be aware that you
made a mistake except that it happened
but don't let it define you and from
there depending on what the situation is
there are a couple of ways out like I
said sort of general across-the-board
advice is to think of what the smallest
lowest risk baby steps are that you can
take so for example let's say you
realize you're in the wrong career
except that it was a mistake you're not
gonna let the mistake define yourself
but you want try to figure out how to
get out and so if someone's in that
position you know any easy way to kind
of test the waters is to experiment with
different areas of interests that could
potentially turn into a career not
marriage is like a cheating but you know
again that you know for for marriage or
romantic partners for example frame it
with alternative I know this looks bad I
know it looks awful experiment however
would like to experiment but you know
for romantic partners you know one thing
that experts do suggest is to take a
little mini break and sort of put
together sort of a private list of pros
and cons about the relationship what are
you enjoying what are you getting out of
it what brings you joy about this
relationship and then conversely what
are the things that stick in your mind
as this is maybe not working out yeah
sort of go over that list and maybe
share it with a really close friend and
just get some outside feedback because
when we're in these situations ourselves
it's really easy to kind of get blinders
about them and not be able to see the
entire situation for all that it is and
see the context happening and so it's
really important to kind of have that
outsider's opinion just to get someone's
thoughts on it yeah and from there you
know you might realize things are tough
but this was a mistake or you might go
the other way and think like okay maybe
this was not actually the best move to
make is it wise to be the author of your
own fate acknowledged the mistake and
fix it or to sit back a little bit and
let things unfold you know if it was
such a big mistake maybe you're out of
the marriage you're at right right it
said life has a way of self-correcting
and there are things that we can only
control only so many things that we can
control ourselves like they're always
going to be factors that are just
completely outside of our control and I
think that kind of comes together with
just acknowledging a situation for what
it is and being really critical and open
and sincere with yourself and just you
know addressing everything that's
happening but being aware not trying to
gloss over it have you made a big
mistake in your life and recovered from
it many many which one would you like to
hear about how about the professional
one so a couple of years ago I did take
a job that I realized very early on not
even two weeks in that it was not the
right job for me
you know I kind of jumped in a little
haphazardly maybe not as informed as
they should have been about what it was
and what Michaels wore and my life
ambitions were and so I took his job and
you know a couple weeks and was like
means it's not working out for me
and so so for me it was a really easy
process to kind of get around because I
realized so quickly that was not what I
wanted to do not what I wanted to be and
so I was able to kind of look at my
options and evaluate and see what I
wanted to be and what the next steps for
me we're going to be and now he works
the New York Times the Harvard of news I
guess it all worked out who knows you
know on the subject of it all working
out there there are a couple
perspectives I like I do actually we
were joking but like the Buddhist
perspective two mistakes yeah actually a
helpful one this sounds completely crazy
but sometimes you think you've made a
mistake and things are falling apart but
in fact if time goes on it turns out to
be things are falling into place
yeah these are not falling apart they're
falling into place right right right so
bad thing happens you're like that's
terrible
ask yourself well time will tell maybe
the fact that I didn't get that job that
I blew that presentation that that
interview went sideways in the long run
great thing and so that is a wonderful
perspective and that's a perspective
that I've written about just try to see
the values of disadvantages or setbacks
because I've read it it's important I
mean what can say all right very good
all right the way anything else do we
good what's the sign-off what's the sign
stay blue no not what we need like a
what's the flip sorry I can't say steak
you mistake-free I'll tell you what be
kind to yourself
how about beautiful I love it like that
thank you Tim great thank you